a lot of people feel like they have to
either be a digital nomad or not a
digital nomad like a nomad or a settler
like they have to either choose the path
of being only in one place and building
a life there or they have to choose a
life on the road whereas i think it's
much more mixed than that you kind of
find the right balance for you so like
do you want a home base at all i have
colleagues who have no home base so they
don't have a home anywhere
uh they don't actually stay anywhere
long enough to to kind of like uh
establish a home base
um and that's like one way to do it but
then there are also ways to do it where
you're just kind of like genuinely
building like a borderless life so maybe
um an example of this is uh my husband
and i like would like to get properties
in the netherlands and malaysia and so
it's not so much that we want to travel
like 365 days per year but it's more
like we want to move between a few
different locations and actually kind of
have home bases there which you can kind
of monetize on airbnb or kind of ways
like that when you're not using them
okay so this i feel like this is the
problem that i have right now where i'm
thinking in my in my mind it's like all
or nothing that i have to be traveling
or i have to be in london and
in my in my mind i'm also kind of
thinking you know like right now i'm
renting a place in in central london
it's pretty expensive and so like the
the sunk cost of that you know plays in
my mind where i think oh i mean i could
go
traveling and go to a cool place for a
month but then i'm kind of quote
throwing money down the drain on rent in
this in this place uh i've been thinking
about like potentially looking to try
and buy a flat in central london or
somewhere in london to use as this home
base but i didn't quite clog that you
could kind of airbnb it out for like
short small small periods of time um
yeah what's what sort of setup would you
recommend for me given
the context
ah
okay so i mean it depends where you want
to spend time right so like are there
particular places in the world that you
visited and you were like this place is
sick i want to spend more time here yeah
a few i think uh tokyo has been pretty
sick i think hoi an in vietnam was
pretty sick i've got family in karachi
so i'd like to kind of spend some time
there um in in pakistan every now and
then
um but i'm still very much thinking that
i don't really know uh
the idea of traveling and living
someplace for one to three months seems
cool but i've never done it to know what
it would actually be like
so i guess my recommendation to get kind
of practical on it is
i try not to remote work anywhere that i
haven't spent a week that's more of a
holiday first and the reason for that is
because
if you are trying to maintain like a
regular working pattern
whilst traveling from place to place and
you find that you are moving like every
month and every time you arrive there's
a problem that you didn't expect eg you
can't get a sim card the wi-fi your
airbnb is rubbish like these kind of
practical issues that can become like
really really draining um and so it can
be good to kind of do a recce like do a
test run so you go somewhere for a week
and one you see if you like it and two
you see what kind of practical problems
you come up against um
you know
bad wi-fi is like a really big one in
the in the minds of nomads but there's
also like a lack of good co-working
space uh accommodation that doesn't look
like the pictures so you end up moving
as soon as you arrive there's kind of a
lot of friction points there
and so i find it really good to go and
visit for a week kind of low pressure
you don't have a lot of work to do or
anything you're just there to kind of
experience the place as a kind of test
run to then go back for one to three
months later um and so i guess my my ali
abdel uh kind of recommendation here
would be for you to kind of explore some
places for a week on that basis of like
could i work here what kind of obstacles
do i think i would encounter and then
plan a trip that's a bit a longer term
it can be good as well to kind of plan
one to three months in a place when
there's something going on so if there's
like halfway through your three-month
trip there's like a big conference going
on and you know that five friends are
gonna be in that place for that
conference it can be a nice way to kind
of like organize your time nice hey
friends thank you so much for watching
if you enjoyed this clip then click here
for the full unedited episode and if you
like that then do please consider
subscribing to the channel it means a
lot thank you so much and have a great
day